- [Instructor] In previous
videos, we talk about how
as we exit the fourth
century, in the 390s,
the emperor Theodosius, he
actually splits the Roman Empire.
We already had the city of Constantinople
being established as a
capital of the empire.
That was done by Constantine in 324,
the city previously known as Byzantium.
But as we enter into the fifth century,
there is an official split between
the Western Roman Empire and
the Eastern Roman Empire.
They're actually governed separately.
Now, also in other videos, we talk about
the eventual fall of the
Western Roman Empire.
Now, one thing to keep in mind,
sometimes when we talk
about the fall of the west,
it somehow implies that
there's no governance left
or there's no kingdoms left.
And nothing could be
further from the truth.
One of the reasons why the
Western Roman Empire fell
is repeated attacks by Germanic tribes,
and after the Western
Roman Empire was gone,
the Germanic tribes, for
the most part, took over.
On the Italian peninsula,
you at first have the kingdom of Odoacer,
but eventually you have rule,
especially as we get into
the late fifth century,
you have the Ostrogothic
Kingdom, Ostrogoths,
the Eastern Goths, the
Eastern Germanic tribes.
Here in North Africa,
you have the Vandals,
another Germanic tribe.
Here in the Iberian peninsula,
you have the Visigoths,
the Western Goths, yet
another Germanic tribe.
Here you have the Burgundians,
you have the Franks.
The word France comes from the
notion of land of the Franks.
Once again, all of these
are Germanic kingdoms
that took over, where before you had
the Western Roman Empire.
Now, as you can see from this map,
and we've talked about
it in previous videos,
it was only the Western
Roman Empire that fell
and fragmented and, for the most part,
came into the hands of
these Germanic tribes.
The Eastern Empire continues on,
and it's often known
as the Byzantine Empire
with its capital at Constantinople.
Now, what we'll see is
that the Byzantine Empire
lasts for almost another 1,000 years,
but its importance in the region
diminishes for most of that period.
It does have one last hurrah, so to speak,
with the reign of Emperor Justinian.
Justinian is able to come to power in 527.
He comes into power with
the help of his uncle,
who's the previous Emperor Justin,
and Justinian is able to
regain much of the land
that was lost to the Germanic tribes.
Over the course of Justinian's reign,
as you can see, they're able
to retake the Italian peninsula
and much of North Africa.
Now, things weren't
always easy for Justinian,
and they are very difficult
at the beginning of his rule
and they get hard near the
end of his rule as well.
In 532, there's significant
rioting in Constantinople,
which is his capital.
It all starts around chariot racing
and the different groups or gangs
that support the different
chariot racing teams,
but it eventually
becomes an all-out revolt
against Justinian.
And many of Justinian's advisors,
including Justinian himself,
they're afraid that they're
gonna be overthrown and killed,
and they think about
fleeing Constantinople.
And this is only five
years into his reign.
This is in 532.
And at that point, his
wife Empress Theodora
stands up and becomes a very
important actor in history.
She has her famous speech
at the point in time
when Justinian and his advisors
were thinking about fleeing,
fear of death.
They thought they were
going to be overthrown.
And here is that famous
quote from Empress Theodora.
The present occasion is too serious
to allow me to follow the convention
that a woman should not
speak in a man's council.
Those whose interests are
threatened by extreme danger
should think only of the
wisest course of action,
not of conventions.
In my opinion, flight
is not the right course,
even if it should bring us to safety.
It is impossible for a person,
having been born into
this world, not to die,
but for one who has reigned,
it is intolerable to be a fugitive.
May I never be deprived
of this purple robe,
the purple robe signifying
royalty, being an empress,
and may I never see the
day when those who meet me
do not call me empress.
If you wish to save yourself,
so she's talking to Justinian
and Justinian's advisors,
if you wish to save yourself, my lord,
there is no difficulty.
We are rich.
Over there is the sea,
and there are the ships.
Yet reflect for a moment whether,
when you have once escaped
to a place of security,
you would not gladly exchange
such safety for death.
As for me, I agree with the adage
that the royal purple
is the noblest shroud.
So, she's saying I would
rather die as an empress
than try to be a fugitive
and just try to live my
life, the rest of my life,
somehow comfortably.
And she's able to convince Justinian,
and they're able to put down
the uprising quite brutally,
killing 30,000 of the people
who are rising up against them.
Now, during that uprising,
much of Constantinople
is burned, including the main
church, the Hagia Sophia,
and it was under Justinian's rule
that the Hagia Sophia gets rebuilt.
And it still exists in
what is now Istanbul today.
Constantinople eventually
gets renamed Istanbul
once it's conquered by the Turks.
And it eventually gets
turned into a mosque,
and today, it is a museum.
The Hagia Sophia literally
means holy wisdom.
You might recognize the
word Sophia from philosophy,
which literally means friend
of wisdom, philosophia.
Now, perhaps what Justinian
is most famous for
is his attempt to better
codify a set of laws.
The Roman Empire, of
course, always had laws,
but Justinian got legal experts
to go and collect the laws of the land,
to make them consistent,
to throw out the laws
that are inconsistent,
to add new laws as necessary.
And he did this over his entire reign,
and he spread them.
And they are often referred
to as the Code of Justinian.
And they would have an influence on the
Byzantine Empire for the next 900 years
and even some influence on some
relatively modern schools of law.
Now, as I've mentioned before,
the reign of Justinian is
considered really the high point
of the Byzantine Empire.
And even as we get into roughly
the second half of his reign,
things start to slide downward,
and over the next 900 years,
are just in a state of decline.
Starting in the 540s,
there's a significant plague
in the Byzantine Empire.
Some accounts I've seen show that
roughly 40% of Constantinople dies,
significant chunk of the population
of the Byzantine Empire dies.
And that makes it more
susceptible to attack
from the various Germanic tribes
throughout Justinian's reign.
And well after Justinian's reign,
there's constant tension
and often conflict
between the Sassanid Persians in the east.
And then, as we go further on,
especially as we get into the
seventh and eighth century,
you have the rise of Islam.
Early Islamic empires are able
to take over the Sassanids
and significantly eat
into the Byzantine Empire
and then even some of
the Germanic kingdoms
in the Iberian peninsula.
And so, this is taking us now,
we're in the middle of the eighth century.
And if we go further on,
we see this once again
gradual decline continue on,
where you have further invasions
into the Byzantine Empire
from Turkish Muslim kingdoms
or Turkish Muslim conquerors,
all the way until we get to 1453,
when Constantinople
itself falls to the Turks
and eventually gets renamed Istanbul.